For me, it all began with a boy.
His name was Ethan.
Bailey, Bailey, Bailey, Bailey.
My name was Bailey, Bailey, Bailey, Bailey.
No!
As the years went by,...
...I could tell my time with Ethan was coming to an end.
Good boy, Bailey.
I'll miss you.
And then, it happened.
I was back.
I didn't have a...
I'm a girl?!
Good girl, good girl.
I had a new purpose.
I was needed again,...
...and again,...
...and again.
Hi, you.
With each new life, I was learning a new lesson.
Have we met before?
Where did you find that?
Okay, ready?
Go!
I tried to make sense out of all the things I've seen.
Was there a point to this journey of mine?
And how did bacon fit in?
If I can get you licking and loving,...
...I have my purpose.